And the negative is female and the order
and the yes, and the positive is male.
And a lot of these things that I
have a lot of trouble, uh, accepting.
Hi there, Steve Kufmann here and today,
I'm going to talk on a different subject.
I'm gonna talk a bit about a book that
I bought called, uh, 10 rules for life.
Excuse me, 12 rules for
life by Jordan Peterson.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
If you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
So, uh, I'm gonna talk about this book
and I'll tell you why, and I'm gonna
relate it a bit to language learning
because that's what I always like to do.
So I became aware of Jordan
Peterson when, uh, he was quite
controversial because he opposed
the sort of, he, he was a professor.
Okay...
step back a bit, professor at the
university of Toronto, professor of
psychology, the university said you now
have to use these gender neutral pronouns.
He said, I'm not going to use
general gender neutral pronouns.
You can't tell me how to speak
or how to use the language.
And he has become a, a leading figure
in sort of opposing what is known as
wokeism in other words, the idea that
everyone has to confirm conform to certain
patterns of behavior um, regarding,
you know, gender categories or race
relations or, uh, attitudes towards
a whole number of things that this is
the accepted correct way of behaving.
And anyone who doesn't behave in this way
is therefore a bad person and not welcome
at a university and so forth and so on.
And this book has been a, a bestseller.
I don't know how many million copies
it's sold and he's written a sequel.
So I said...
and he's Canadian.
He's from, uh, Fairview, Alberta.
And I'm very familiar with that
area, Peace River Region in
Alberta, because I did a lot of
business there in forest products.
And I know the area, I know the people,
some of the people, you know, up in
that area, great area, great country.
So I began to read through it and
I'd be interested in the reaction
of people who have read the book.
Uh, I sort of leafed through it.
Um, my reaction is that he has sort of
this tremendous knowledge of psychology
of, uh, mythology, of religion.
And so he sort of describes, you
know, a world that our lives are in
his view, tragic or full of evil.
I mean, eventually we die and there
are lots of bad things that happen.
Bad things have always happened.
And so in this world of chaos,
then how should we lead our lives?
Uh, in his first chapter, which
he calls uh, you know, stand up
straight with your shoulders back.
In other words, you should have a very
erect posture and it ties that in some
way to this idea of, of a hierarchy,
uh, in the animal kingdom hierarchy in
amongst human beings, that that structure
or hierarchy is kind of embedded in our
genetic, uh, you know, we're predisposed
to be more dominant or less dominant.
Uh, he even suggests that the
chaos portion of lives is sort
of, uh, and the negative is
female and the order and the yes.
And the positive is male.
And a lot of these things that I have
a lot of trouble, uh, accepting, um,
And in fact, as a general rule, I
find that his 12 rules don't really
relate to the subject matter that
he discusses within each chapter.
He has a chapter for each rule.
And so instead you have these
themes that sort of pervade all of
these chapters, and that is this
sense of sort of a dark world.
And the only way we can survive is
if we maintain certain structures, he
seems to favor a patriarchy because
historically, and perhaps in the animal
kingdom, the male is typically stronger.
Uh, and, uh, that's a good thing.
And, uh, where there is, and,
and all a while, of course, he's
pushing back against this sort of
woke thing, which makes any sort
of expression of power a bad thing.
Whereas in fact, to a large extent,
people who have more power, but
not always, but in many cases, they
have earned that position of power
because they have certain abilities.
And so he stresses this, that, uh,
we can't just condemn the patriarchy,
but by the same token countries that
are where the patriarchal sort of
pattern is stronger, aren't necessarily
happier countries, uh, any survey of
happiness typically shows countries
like Denmark, uh, and Scandinavia is
having the highest happiness coefficient
to the extent that we can measure that
effectively, it's somewhat subjective.
And those countries typically have sort
of a less dominant patriarchal structure
than some more traditional societies.
But nevertheless, he does make the point
that the world we live in is one where,
you know, the individual is important.
In fact, that's, I should
go there right away.
I saw a video of his, I did some
research on the internet where he
makes the point that our Western
society is, uh, very successful.
And, and so again, he's defending
Western society from those who almost
systematically want to tear  it down.
Fair enough.
Uh, there's definitely a tendency for
intellectuals, people at universities
to want to tear down the established
or to criticize the established order.
Uh, this was the case with the prevalence
of Marxist and the economics department.
It's the, uh, example today where
in all of the humanities, you
have this strong preponderance of
people who are quote "progressive".
uh, and who are therefore very
critical of the established society.
When in fact the, the established
society is really not that bad.
However, where I have trouble with,
with Jordan Peterson is he calls this
Western society, Western culture.
But, but the fact is that it's modern
society, that Western society, 500
years ago, a thousand years ago, over
2000 years ago in Rome and Greece,
where half the population were slaves.
Uh, in, in the middle ages when people
were persecuted for what they thought,
for their religions, uh, not that great
at a time, in many cases throughout
history where other civilizations it
might be, you know, the, the Chinese,
uh, civilization during the, uh, the
Tang Dynasty, for example, maybe ... was
a nicer place to live than London.
uh, you know, I get my dates...
but certainly six, you know, middle
ages in, uh, Europe wasn't all
that great in terms of lifespan,
in terms of the sophistication, in
terms of respect for individuals.
And so and so on, uh, in the modern age,
uh, county, like Japan has a legal system,
uh, which is, uh, certainly no worse than,
uh, in Western Europe or north America.
It certainly has health
outcomes that are better.
Uh, it, uh, functions very
effectively as a society.
So I, I think this idea sort of to
stick up for Western society and we're
the best and stuff, I find that a
little bit inaccurate, uh, to say the
least, and even to the extent of the
sort of technological achievements in
Western society, they are the result
of technological advances in other
countries, mathematics in India and, and.
Uh, science in China 2000 years ago.
And, uh, even, uh, you know, Arab
and, and Muslim scholars who sort of,
uh, kept greek learning and Indian
learning and, and Islamic learning,
and eventually brought that back to
the west so that in say the 12, 13th,
14th century, many of these things
were rediscovered and this then led
to the, uh, Renaissance and so forth.
And so on the world is
an interconnected place.
And I think, you know, to use his, uh,
imagery, you know, to stand up on your
hin legs and say ours is the best.
Uh, I don't think he's very helpful.
I think if he just, as I'm now learning
so much more about Iran and Persian
history and, and the, the, uh, Cyrus' the
cylinder where he recognized the freedom
of religion and freedom of, of different
ethnic groups, groups to have every right
in the, in the old, uh, Persian empire.
It, it, it kind of enables you to see
the world through different lenses,
the lenses of different languages.
And, uh, and I think that gives you
a better perspective, uh, and...
but I do agree that, um,
that one shouldn't be overly
critical of, of our society.
You know, there's a lot of this sort of
anti-capitalist society, but I'm always
aware of the fact that the products that
I use, this camera that I'm using, which
is made in Japan, or maybe it's made in
China under licensed from the Japanese,
uh, the food I eat the products I use
the, the daily functioning of our society.
It's, you know, all kinds of people
making my life richer and better.
That's how our societies have evolved.
Of course it ends at some point.
Uh, I don't think that
people are all out to get me.
I don't think there's so many evil people
out there, but there are evil people.
And so in terms of how we lead
our lives, uh, I don't think we
should say it's all the individual.
It's not all the individual.
I think we need to obviously live
our lives in a way, you know, we are
responsible for our lives, but we
are also helpful to others, which is
in a way in his book, but it's sort
of hidden in amongst all the sort
of dark mythology and, you know,
biblical references to punishments
and, uh, and all kinds of dark stuff.
He creates this sort of sense that
the world, this, uh, chaotic place and
the it's sort of difficult to extract
yourself from the tragedy and the pain
of living and to do that, you gotta, you
know, follow these rules, basic self-help
things there that are universal, like
tell the truth and listen to others.
And, uh, you know, look after
yourself, be responsible to
yourself and all this stuff is good.
And, but, but, um, I think the
main reason why his, his book
has, um, been so successful.
I think there are two reasons.
One is there's quite a breadth of,
of information about psychology and,
and mythology and religions and all
these different ways that people
try to explain the mystery of life.
And, and then he extracts out of
that, a few rules he claims that can
help mitigate this, this, uh, chaos
and enable you to live a meaningful.
But where that meaning is you
have to find for yourself.
I think obviously our families
provide meaning, but there are
also dysfunctional families.
Uh, for me, um, learning languages
provide meaning because I discover more
about different cultures, uh, people
who are bird Watchers, uh, people
who are, uh, involved in charities.
There was a gentleman, uh,
discovered the other day, who...
he has set up his whole house as a, as
a, as, you know, uh, recycling Depot and
you can take your empty milk bottles,
your empty, you know, water bottles,
your empty wine bottles, take 'em up
there, drop them there and he will make
sure that that is converted into...
because the recycling
system pays you for them.
And from that, he gives food
vouchers to homeless people.
That's his life, that's meaning.
He has...
that's his meaning.
Wonderful.
So we find meaning wherever it is like
I, uh, and, and I think where I, I
agree with, with, um, JordanPeterson
is pushback on all this woke stuff
like this gender neutral pronouns.
It doesn't matter if, if there is a
non-binary person, a transgendered
person and I refer to him or her as
him or her, and they say to me, no,
I'd rather be referred to as this.
Fine.
Um, the idea that somehow a
gender neutral pronoun has some
great significance I don't buy.
Uh, in Persian and in Turkish,
they have gender neutral pronouns.
And yet both of those societies are
more patriarchal and less tolerant
of non-traditional gender roles or
non-traditional sexual orientation.
So the fact that that, uh, gender neutral
pronoun is used is meaningless and why,
you know, whatever the number is of these
non-binary people in our society, I don't
know, 0.01%, 2%, whatever the number is,
why should everyone have to change their,
um, speech patterns to accommodate this?
The main purpose is to demonstrate
how progressive we are.
See, I use my preferred...
like just by saying my
preferred pronouns are he/him.
Now I've said I'm progressive.
It's meaningless actually.
Uh, it's like in the company
that I ran, we have always
hired the best person available.
We've had Japanese people,
Chinese people, Sikhs there.
We've had Romanians, Russians.
Um, I don't know Filipinos.
We've had gay people.
We've had everybody, the best
person we can find always, but
I don't believe in saying I am
a diversity, you know, employer.
I sign on to the diversity statement.
I don't need all of that.
That's the sort of virtue signaling.
Rather the principle should be you
hire the best person available.
And I am responsible to
myself, to my employees.
And that's how I, I, so to that,
making these kinds of virtue
signaling statements, Uh, a condition
of employment or, uh, you know,
the whole department's set up to
deal with diversity and diversity
is better than lack of diversity.
For example, I don't buy that
because Japan, uh, Korea, Finland,
they don't have much diversity
and their successful societies.
And you have other societies like Canada.
If you go to Toronto, Vancouver, Montreal,
you're gonna find a tremendous diversity
of religion, race, and ethnicity.
But what really matters is
diversity of points of view.
And I don't think that the societies
that are diverse ethnically or in
terms of gender are necessarily
better, uh, than less diverse.
But I think it's probably a good
idea to have a diversity of views.
And in that regard, I think Jordan
Peterson, while I find a lot of his
stuff, I don't necessarily agree with
it's valuable to have people like that who
are pushing back against this attempted
you know conformity imposition on people.
You must say this, you must
make a statement on diversity.
You must, uh, use gender neutral
pronouns and so forth and so on.
So with that, I think I've stirred
up hopefully a bit of controversy.
And, but I think diversity of views
is important and we should respect
everyone's, uh, point of view and
be willing to, uh, discuss and
defend our views and also take into
consideration the, uh, counter argument.
There you have it.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.